you have to drink it really fast
right okay so we get an afternoon with
joel trot on concentrations
um concentrations all of us know them
and love them
they're how you say that something bad
doesn't happen and she's
like one line and a proof that some
concentration with some russian name
is what you need to make it all go
through but you know really it is a
critical area of many of our fields it's
one of the
few things we all have in common so
it gets interesting and complicated when
we get into the multivariate situation
you know it's matrices and uh so we have
a world expert on all the complications
that arise in how to get around them
here
and i think joel you're gonna do three
one-hour lectures kind of
that's a variant on our little model
here and we'll see how that goes
and i believe no powerpoint right well
there will be a little
maybe a little all right anyway turn it
over i'll wake the computer back up
all right so
i'm going to begin with some preparatory
remarks um first of all
um really like to thank the organizers
for their invitation this is a beautiful
new facility
and i'm excited to tell you about
a recent strand of work on concentration
inequalities for matrices we have
three whole hours together um so i
thought maybe i'd
tell you a little about my life maybe
you'd like to hear about the time i
got kidnapped in morocco
okay you don't want to hear that so um
all right
so i am sensitive to the fact that we're
going to be here
together for three hours and that you
know
as boring as it is to talk for three
hours it is even more boring to listen
for three hours and so i'm gonna do my
very best to
keep you engaged the whole time um i'd
like to invite you to put away
your devices um you'll probably find the
talk more interesting if you're actually
um
uh interacting with me and
the slides of course um like mike i'm
not going to enforce this rule
except by glaring at you and uh you're
giggling at whatever comes up on your uh
facebook feed all right so the first
part of this talk
will be on the slides but i hate doing
math on slides because it goes by way
too fast you can't understand anything
and so after some introductory remarks
here on the
overhead we're gonna switch to uh the
whiteboard and we'll do the rest of the
presentation um in ink okay
so let's go oh i almost forgot
uh there are lecture notes on this
material that i wrote for nips last year
and you can find them here at
this address
so go ahead and download copy if you
like the lecture notes have a whole lot
of examples in them
of the ideas that i'll be talking about
in their applications
today i'm not going to do so many
examples i'm going to do more in the way
of math because i
think that you all might be more
interested in understanding a bit about
the ideas behind these tools rather than
the slavish repetition
of the application of these tools which
is basically the same every single time
as i'll emphasize so i don't want to
keep going through that over and over
again i'd rather tell you about some of
the backgrounds
but you can get the notes here there's
also a set of um
slides from nips which also has
applications described
and if you'd really like to see the
slavish repetition
of one example after another you can
find it there
all right so let me start out by telling
you a little bit about where random
matrices
came from and where they are now so
peter forrester who wrote a book on
random matrices traces the origins back
to a paper of
hurwitz in 1898
um or maybe has collected works from
1898 but he was studying a problem in
the geometry of numbers and he had the
need to average over a
unitary group and what is a random
unitary matrix
oh sorry what is a typical member of the
unitary group but a random unitary
matrix
and so his formula may be viewed as one
of the first examples of
random matrices in the literature
these ideas really um started to gather
steam in statistics in the 20.
so this smiling gentleman with the large
forehead
is john wishart so he was interested in
covariance estimation for multivariate
normal distributions
back in the day before people had
computers and they did a lot of
their statistics by hand and so it
really helped to have analytic formulas
that you could
tabulate um or work with analytically
and so he was interested in
um the behavior of a standard normal
or a normal population and what its
covariance
empirical covariance would look like so
i've drawn a page out of his paper here
you can see multivariate distribution
use of quadratic coordinates where he
changes variables to diagonalize this
matrix and then
in gory detail cranks out the density
of a matrix that we now know as a wish
heart matrix
so here's the formula it's
not very enlightening but
this is one of the first examples where
this came up and since then
statisticians have continued to use
random matrices as models for data and
that was the application that he was
interested in
okay the next place that i'm aware of
the random matrices arose was
in numerical linear algebra which is um
due to john von neumann the smiling
gentleman here with the
large forehead so he's standing here
next to
the very first computer which was
built in the early 1950s so before
john von neumann had this computer
in the 40s he started getting interested
in the possibilities of using computers
to
solve numerical problems you know before
that computers were
um rooms full of usually women
with note cards and adding machines who
would
crank through the computations by hand
so he was interested in the prospects
for the first digital computer and one
of the things he thought you might like
to do with a digital computer to solve
linear algebra problems
okay so he before he ever had a computer
invented the lud composition of a matrix
identified the idea of rounding error
analysis
performed a rounding error analysis for
lu decomposition
and described how you would implement
this on a
digital computer that at this point did
not exist
so um smart guy
in the second paper he wrote on the
subject
he thought that perhaps it would be a
good idea to model the errors in these
arithmetic computations as random
and so if you're working with a matrix
and you're trying to decompose the
matrix and you're making errors in the
coordinates of the matrix
and you think about those arrows as
maybe being well modeled by something
random you wind up with a
random matrix and so john von neumann
said well maybe
this is a good model let's investigate
his properties
and so he worked out the tail bound here
for the top eigenvalue of a
random matrix that he thought might
arise from his floating point
computation
and you can see that the probability of
the norm of the matrix
exceeds such and such and so forth so
this was
an example of random matrices in
numerical linear algebra as many of you
may know random matrices were
subsequently banished
from linear algebra as was any other
kind of randomness and it wasn't until
um
the late 90s with the work of santosh
impala and ravi khanna
and some of their colleagues that
randomness
really found its way back into this
field as a central idea
we'll talk a little bit more about that
later so random matrices were used to
model
floating point errors in linear algebra
around 1950.
now a third place where random matrices
arose back in the day
um this is perhaps one of the most
famous um
was in nuclear physics so
if you try and model
um nuclear reactions
you can understand small atoms pretty
easily
using um exact calculations but when the
atoms get bigger and more complicated
the physicists found that the techniques
that they had just weren't tractable
anymore they weren't able to
make computations to understand the
energy spectra of these
atoms as they were undergoing this um
type of solar nuclear reaction
so eugene wigner was the first
researcher who had the surmise that
perhaps
they could model the hamiltonian the
operator that described the evolution of
this
process using a random matrix so he
proposed that in the early 1950s
and he is
depicted here on his photo from the
nobel foundation he won the nobel prize
um for uh work related to this um
so in a paper from the annals of math in
1955 he considered the matrix that's now
known as a wigner matrix
which is to say plus minus one random
entries on the off diagonals and
the diagonal entries with a different
distribution and so
in this paper he worked out the what we
now call the limiting spectral
distribution of this matrix
and it turned out this is a rather good
model for the
energy spectra of a heavy atom
undergoing a solar nuclear reaction so
it was really a brilliant
connection that he made here and
subsequently physicists really started
wailing on the random matrices dyson
developed his
three-fold path they studied a variety
of other random matrices
and these matrices are now so well
understood that people understand the
higher order fluctuations of um you know
any collection of 17 eigen values that
you might
wish to take and so this was really an
extraordinarily successful line of
research and for the kind of random
matrices
that these techniques apply to we know
everything
unfortunately um there are a lot of
other random matrices about which we
know nothing
which is to say most of them and part of
the purpose of the research i'll be
telling you about
this afternoon is to say something
about other kinds of random matrices
that don't come from these classical
ensembles that the physicists
understood so well starting from the
1950s
okay so why would you care about random
matrices if you're not interested in
slow nuclear reactions or multivariate
statistics or in
floating point errors so let me tell you
about a few of the applications that
have come up in
uh recent history so the first one i'd
like to mention
which is um getting highlighted here in
part because we're going to have a
tutorial on it
later this week and has been one of the
most successful applications
is the role of randomness in linear
algebra more precisely in matrix
approximation
so the problem here is you have a large
matrix that's approximately low rank
and you'd like to produce an
approximation to that matrix
so um people use this to do principal
component analysis a huge number of
other applications
i'm not going to motivate for you and so
it turns out that
random matrices play a critical role in
one of the basic algorithms for
addressing this problem
so the idea here is that
you'd like to approximate the range of a
which is a low dimensional subspace in
the
codomain of the matrix remember it's a
low rank matrix so it
basically kills a whole bunch of the
dimensions so you can think of the age
the range as being a flat
and the way that you can go about doing
this
is by pulling a random vector out of the
sky multiplying this into the matrix a
and you'll obtain a vector here in the
range
okay so you found one direction in the
range okay let's try that again we'll
reach up in the sky we'll pull down
another random vector
we'll multiply it into matrix a and
we'll get another vector here in the
range of the matrix
now it's random so it's probably not
pointed the same direction as the first
vector we pulled out
so we found another direction okay this
is looking promising so repeat this for
a while
and eventually after
we've pulled k random vectors if the
range of a is k dimensions
we'll have a collection of k linearly
independent vectors in a k dimensional
space
and of course those vectors then span
that space
so if we want to find a basis for the
range of the matrix all we have to do is
orthogonalize
those vectors okay so we can express
this in terms of
random matrices in the following way we
assume that we have a target matrix a
that we'd like to approximate
we collect those random vectors omega 1
up to omega k into the columns of a
random matrix
omega we multiply that random matrix
into a
to obtain a random matrix y whose
columns are the vectors here
on the right hand side and by
forming a qr decomposition of y to
expose its
range we can construct a basis
for the range of a okay this is a very
simple algorithm for finding
the range of a low rank matrix
using randomness and what makes this
algorithm tick
are the properties of this random matrix
omega so to understand the behavior of
this algorithm
you need to understand how the random
matrix omega interacts
with the target matrix a that you're
trying to approximate
and you'll learn a lot more about that
later this week from
one of our colleagues who's giving that
talk to you
petros both of you all right
so um these guys are the leading experts
on this problem
and um you'll see very precisely how
you need to understand random matrices
to understand this type of algorithm
okay so this is a very successful
approach
but there are all sorts of other
algorithmic applications of random
matrices that members of
um our community and other communities
have developed so here's a quick tour of
some of these ideas
so there's the idea of random
sparsification
say someone hands you a huge matrix and
you'd like to perform a spectral
computation
one way to do that is to randomly throw
away most of the entries just zero them
out
and then rescale the entries you decide
to keep now you've got a sparse matrix
and on average it sort of looks like the
matrix that you started with
and so you can perform the spectral
computations on the sparse matrix
instead of the
original matrix you started with and
sparse linear algebra tends to be faster
than dense linear algebra so
this may be a way to accelerate those
computations
so one way random matrices arise in
applications is through sparsification
randomly zeroing out entries
um people use sub sampling so mike
jordan probably talked a little bit
about this this morning in connection
with the
um bootstrap yes
no no you need to throw the entries away
in proportion to their magnitude
so there's some nice papers on that by
um christos
um dude sodas and petrostorneas and um
toso zuzias a bunch of other folks
demetrious aclioptus you'll notice these
guys are all greek
um i don't know what that means
okay
you'll probably have some insight on
this though
all right um sub sampling so people
throw away
um portions of the data in an effort to
compute kernels approximately
dimension reduction we heard about that
in the last talk by alex andone
so we might want to perform a nearest
neighbor calculation for data in a very
high dimensional space
one way to do that is to squash the data
into low dimensional space by
multiplying it
into a random matrix and the properties
of the random matrix are essential to
understanding the performance of the
dimension reduction method
another method i really like because it
has a different flavor
from the first three where you're taking
data and tossing a whole bunch of it out
randomly and then analyzing
how much damage you did using the
properties of random matrices
is an application in combinatorial
optimization so
the method of relaxation and rounding
the idea here is you have a very hard
optimization problem
that you would like to solve but it's
intractable
so instead you replace it by a close by
problem that is tractable
you solve the tractable problem and then
after you've got a solution to that
you apply some random procedure to take
the solution from the
tractable problem and round it back to a
solution to the
intractable problem that satisfies the
constraints of the original problem
and if your decision variable happened
to be a matrix you would really need to
understand random matrices to
push through this calculation so there's
some very nice papers on
matrix optimization problems involving
spectral norm constraints and quadratic
constraints that use exactly these kinds
of ideas
so random matrices play a role in
combinatorial optimization as well
so these are all ways in which
understanding the properties of random
matrices is essential to
develop and analyze modern algorithms
any questions on any of these
so when i got learned how to um
teach when i was at the university of
michigan as a postdoc they
warned me that if you don't wait at
least six seconds after asking a
question
no one will have had an opportunity to
actually formulate a question
so that explains the lengthy and awkward
pauses
after i ask you whether you have any
questions so
yeah see on your
last data slide was it uh theorem the
upper bound of the spectrum of random
matrix
yes yeah it's in this 1951 paper with
goldstein
um yes a pretty extraordinary
yeah um goes back a long way
anything else perhaps a comment is that
you you didn't mention
that there is a online in the theory of
banner spaces
that starts i i would imagine
perhaps late 60s yeah no man's work on
concentration and measures um
certainly can be interpreted in terms of
the properties of random matrices
um i guess i'll mention a couple other
things while we're at it in terms of
combinatorics
you can certainly model the adjacency
matrix of a random graph as a
random matrix and by understanding its
second eigenvalue
say you can understand something about
the connectivity or the mixing
properties of
a walk on random walk on the graph
another place this turned up in the
early 70s was in montgomery's work on
the zeros of the riemann zeta function
it turns out that the
eigenvalues of a random matrix provide
an excellent model for the spacing of
the zeros of the zeta function
so these things are everywhere um
these days it's i think kind of hard to
find a field that
has not been touched by random matrix
theory
um anything else
okay so um this isn't by any means
comprehensive it's just intended to be
motivational
okay another place that random matrices
come up
is when we try to model data now i like
to
place a caveat on this slide which is
that um
models do not necessarily describe
reality
with any accuracy and so one of the
dangers
is that people analyze algorithms or
other methods
by considering a random model and then
forget that they
were modeling something
um become convinced that the outcome of
their analysis is an actual description
of reality
okay these are just models they
may be more or less accurate
descriptions of what's going on in the
background they may be more or less
informative
but they do let you try to say something
about the behavior of
algorithms or other kinds of
computational problems
in a sort of average setting now whether
that average setting looks anything like
anything you would ever encounter
is a point that should be investigated
okay
so um high dimensional data analysis
this is like a wish arts example with
that um
multi-dimensional gaussian model so
statisticians
love using random matrices to model
multivariate data
sometimes it's a good model maybe other
times not so much
but very popular
wireless communications so um you can
use a random matrix to model
um the fading in a wireless channel
and um tulino and purdue have been very
successful in applying methods for
random matrix
theory to understand these problems and
it appears this is actually a pretty
good model
for um this type of phenomenon
and one other example if you have
a superposition of two structured
signals um an important algorithmic
problem with signal processing is to
pull those
two signals apart from each other using
the fact that they're structured
and if you assume that the two signals
are oriented
randomly with respect to each other they
don't have anything in common then you
can often solve this problem using
um optimization based algorithms and
this random model for the orientation of
the signals really is very important to
help understand how these algorithms
perform
whether it describes actual signal
processing problems well
hard to say but in all of these cases
the behavior of a random matrix is
essential to understanding
a computational or statistical problem
okay one other place that random
matrices come up
is in theoretical applications people
use these as
examples or counter examples for a
variety of problems
so one place that comes up in the theory
of algorithms is in the smooth
analysis of gaussian elimination so we
know that
if you perform gaussian elimination on a
worst case matrices
matrices okay on a worst-case matrix
the sequence of pivots can grow
exponentially quickly
but that never actually happens and one
compelling theoretical explanation for
why that might be the case is um
this moved analysis due to dan spielman
and his collaborators in which
he showed that for most matrices close
to a given matrix the
pivots don't grow okay and that depends
essentially on the property of
a fixed matrix plus a small random
matrix
okay so random agencies play a role in
the smooth
analysis problem they come up in
combinatorics so one of the simplest
constructions of an expander graph is
via a random matrix they come up in high
dimensional geometry
as pointed out so for example if you're
interested in the structure of a
random slice of a high dimensional body
you can interpret this um
a spectral property of a random matrix
and very recently we've seen these
things coming up in quantum information
theory is
counter examples to very natural
conjectures about the capacity of a
quantum channel
and again the properties of these random
matrices were really essential
to understanding um
their to producing these counter
examples so these things are everywhere
these theoretical applications are nice
because you know the math is true
so it's not like the models where the
model could be a good model or a bad
model these um
really do demonstrate um in the first
case the
something about the behavior of an
algorithm or the existence of a
combinatorial object
or a counter-example about
how we can transmit information through
a quantum system
okay any questions on any of this
background you referring to
any mechanism i mean a measurable map
from a um
very general and that's the trouble like
if someone says
here's a random matrix whose entries are
independent and identically distributed
standard normal
variables then we know everything about
that matrix i mean
this is of course a huge achievement but
in particular i'm including examples
that are a lot more um
fussy
like you said for only for ghosting
because you said 4-1-1 we also know
everything
no we don't actually it turns out that
this is shockingly hard
because yeah i mean i remember at some
point there was this
you know eigenvector infinity norm sorry
that's right
question that remains yeah i think that
there's been a little bit of progress on
this recently localization of
eigenvectors for somewhat
general matrices with independent
entries
oh i'm sorry i apologize she was asking
about um whether we know everything
about
matrices whose entries are random plus
minus one
a matrix is to variables seen right i
mean
yeah these problems are extraordinarily
difficult in part because the
distributions are discrete
but it's in part because they don't have
the same kind of symmetries as a
gaussian matrix
so when i say we know everything i'm
really referring to a very small number
of classical ensembles
and beyond that um
sea dragons
i mean it's not really much of an
exaggeration
um more questions
this is just to persuade you that what
we're going to be talking about is
somewhat relevant
and interesting now i'd like to tell you
a little bit about my approach to random
matrices now
um i read an article in new york times
that said that if you sing my way in a
karaoke bar in the philippines someone
will knife you
um and i'm hoping this audience is a
little gentler
um and
well if i went down that road you would
not be gentle
so um in particular i'd like to
emphasize this isn't really my
approach to solving problems involving
random matrices this is
really a method that's developed over
the last 15 years or so with the
contributions of a whole lot of people
some of them are indicated at the bottom
of the slides but
i think really in the last few years
it's become clear that there is an
alternative approach to dealing with a
lot of random matrices that come up in
practice
and um it's extremely powerful
um although it does have some
limitations of its own
and uh
there yes of course the increasing
uh not longest increasing subsequence
exactly which at least
should be mentioned as one of the nicest
connections between the metrics theory
in the community
yes so um another important example in
combinatorics is
the problem of the length of the longest
increasing um subsequence in a random
uh rambly permuted sequence so this is
studied by
jinho bake and some other folks and
there are some connections random
matrices but i'm not really that
familiar with the work
so all right so um
let me tell you about a couple
principles to um addressing random
matrix problems that
have sort of become clear over the last
few years so
back in the 1980s there was a barbie
doll
that was released on the market that had
a little string you could pull the
string and it would say various um
kind of offensive things um one of which
is that um
math is tough now of course the irony in
that case is that as we all know math is
in fact tough and barbie was entirely
correct
on this point
so her detractors perhaps were um and
didn't appreciate the depth of that
comment
you can find um a video of this barbie
doll
on youtube if you're interested but of
course i know you put away all your
devices so it'll
have to wait um i think another piece of
evidence in favor of this point if you
don't trust barbie's opinion
is um to have a look at any monograph on
random matrix theory and this will
persuade you of my point
and i don't mean this is to detract from
the work that people have done which is
beautiful and remarkable but it is not
easy
i spent a long time trying to learn a
lot of this material without a lot of
success
and i don't think it's because of the
exposition i think it's just because
this stuff is hard and it really
requires a large investment of time it
requires ideally the help of a
practitioner who can
show you what's important teach you
about the intuitions behind the
different methods
help you see your way through you know
moment calculations that go on for 10
pages
it's a really very sophisticated area
what i'm going to tell you about is kind
of brain dead
and that's part of the reason i think
it's useful
it allows us to solve
lots and lots of random matrix problems
without
much fuss doesn't always get exactly the
right answer
but it usually comes close enough that
it can be very informative about the
behavior of algorithms or statistical
procedures or
a variety of other problems that arise
in the theory of big
data all right
so there are two principles behind this
method the first one is
that in lots of applications the random
matrix you care about
can be written as a sum of independent
random matrices
so i have denoted this with a giant
sigma um we have a random matrix
z and we have written it as a sum of
some other random matrices s k
which are independent from each other so
it turns out this is shockingly common
um there are lots and lots of situations
you can chop a complicated random matrix
into pieces
that are a lot simpler and that are
independent from each other
and so if you can understand the
properties of those
some ends then you can tie all this
together
to understand properties of the random
matrix c so that's the first principle
we can write
random matrices as sums of independent
random matrices or
nearly independent they're a variety of
alternatives and second of all there are
exponential concentration inequalities
for the spectral norm
of a sum of independent random matrices
so this is the um
second part of this approach so once
you've understood
that z can be decomposed in this fashion
then you can harness the properties of
those sum and sk
to fill in the blank here and understand
the likely size of the spectronorma z it
turns out for a lot of applications
that's all the information you need
so two principles write random matrices
as independent sums
and then apply concentration
inequalities to understand
the eigenvalues of the random matrix
okay so maybe you'll get to this but can
you take frontline instead of upper
bound on this picture
well no no because there's an extra log
factor yeah
so this is one of the trade-offs you
make i'll touch on this in a minute
yeah any question about these two
principles i'm only doing one example
today
normally i beat people over the head
with this for um two to three hours
where i proceed to
chop up random matrices into independent
sums and then
um beat them to death with inequalities
today we're going to be talking about
math instead because
it's a little less repetitive
any questions on this
so um let me summarize the vision here
behind this work
um and again this isn't my vision it's
um
sort of the culmination of a lot of
research in this area
okay so random matrices are hard to deal
with
we're going to write them as an
independent sum and apply a package
concentration inequality
and usually this amounts to some
arithmetic half a page or a page of work
and we get very strong results on the
behavior of the random matrix
now the two pluses are that there's a
very wide range of applicability
and these methods are very simple to use
i'll try and provide some concrete
evidence of that for you in a minute
the minus is that sometimes you lose a
log factor
so in contrast with the classical
ensembles like matrices with gaussian
entries about which we know everything
we don't get quite the right answer in
some situations but the loss is
controlled it's pretty small and so for
a lot of problems
it doesn't really matter as it said what
is a logarithm
between friends
so um my group and i have all sorts of
papers about this this is um
mostly um painfully technical um but
as i indicated there is a set of lecture
notes that introduces some of these
ideas
and there are a lot of examples in the
lecture notes so i'm gonna refer you to
the lecture notes for most of the
examples
but in case you get really enthusiastic
about this
there's a lot of reading you can do
and they're actually still interesting
open questions if anyone wishes to
discuss that later on
this fall okay any questions on the sort
of preparatory remarks about
why you should care about random
matrices or the approach we're going to
take to studying them
all right the six seconds are up and uh
we'll now move to the blackboard
all right
yeah wait from the tournament
okay so let's do an example of a
familiar matrix that can be chopped into
independent pieces
so this example comes from statistics
and goes in some sense all the way back
to wish art
and this is the sample covariance matrix
so here's the setup we have a
statistical problem
where somewhere in the universe there is
a population
of multivariate subjects
and we'll introduce a random vector
x
that contains the distribution of each
one of those variables for a
given subject
so this is a random vector
it clearly has length p and
we're going to assume that the
expectation of this random vector is
zero
so all the variables of zero mean um
just to simplify the discussion
obviously there's correlation i mean the
coordinates can be called the
coordinates may be correlated but each
one is zero mean
you can do all this without zero mean
but there's just more stuff to carry
around
okay so the covariance matrix describes
the correlations
and we obtain this by
multiplying x by its transpose and
computing the expectation
so the entries of this matrix are
xj times xk multiplied together and
averaged
and because these are zero mean these
really are coral
sorry covariances okay so the covariance
matrix
is a p by p matrix that tabulates the
covariance
between each pair of entries in the
matrix
and the random vector x okay so we would
like to
estimate a from data
okay so what kind of data might we hope
to have collected
well we might believe that we have
drawn independent
copies
of the random vector x so if this is
some subject
we imagine that there are n identical
copies of this subject and that we've
interrogated each one of them
to find out the values of each of these
p variables so
freshmen at berkeley and we found out
their sat scores and
their free throw percentage and um i
don't know the number of um
shots that they drink on a typical
friday night and all these other things
okay so we've collected n independent
copies of the random vector
and the natural approach to trying to
estimate the covariance
is to form the sample covariance
which is the random matrix
i'm denote a hat which is obtained
by
taking each one of the random vectors
forming its outer product
and averaging them together
so this is what's called a plug-in
estimator we've taken the formula for
the covariance
and we've plugged in the data
okay now we would really like the sample
covariance matrix to be a good estimator
for the covariance
and we'd like to understand just how
well or how badly we've done with this
estimate now
this is random so different realizations
are going to be better or worse
and first of all we can take note that
this is a reasonable estimate
because by the linearity of expectation
this is just
the expectation of the sample covariance
is this guy
each one of these is the covariance
there are n copies
we divide by n and so we get the
covariance matrix
so in other words the sample covariance
is an unbiased estimator
for the covariance and
by the way that we have used the zero
mean assumption to
make sure this all works out neatly okay
so
it's a good estimate on average but in
any particular
case any particular draw of the data how
well did we do
well the idea is that we're going to
analyze this by
using matrix concentration inequalities
now what makes us think that we could
apply these ideas
any thoughts
why look it is a sum of independent
random matrices
you can see how this gets tiring pretty
fast
so a hat is a
sum of independent
random matrices
and so we will apply matrix
concentration
okay so we don't know any matrix
concentration inequalities yet so i'm
going to have to tell you about one
so the
result i'm going to tell you about is
probably the most useful of the matrix
concentration inequalities
and it is a result known as matrix
bernstein
um how many of you are familiar with the
scalar bernstein inequality
um but not everyone okay
you don't need any matrix stuff because
you can handle each other
separately you can but it depends on the
kind of error estimate that you want to
get
so if you'd like to get a spectral norm
error estimate which tells you in
particular
you've done a good job estimating every
marginal of the distribution
then you really need something stronger
than entry-wise
and the trouble is there are a lot of
marginals that you might have to control
so that's actually the difficulty in
this problem
so what we're going to want
is an estimate for this kind of quantity
here so how far is um
the sample covariance estimator from the
covariance okay
so it's not that we have any question
about wanting this is
really is what we want if we want to
understand the marginals of the
distribution
so change that to a period okay so the
result that we're going to use
is something called the matrix bernstein
inequality
so there are a bunch of people who
contributed to the development of this
result
um so um
write down a couple names here david
gross
actually let me start out with um all's
vetted in winter
i'll tell you more about these guys in a
little bit and their contribution
um so david gross i think in 2000 um
nine
um developed a matrix bursting
inequality ben recht
um in 2009 developed a matrix bernstein
inequality
um roberto oliveira
in 2010 developed a weaker version of
this and independently
um in 2010 i developed the version that
i'm going to show you
so lots and lots of folks have
contributed to this
and these two results are roughly
equivalent
and that's what i'm going to be telling
you about so
here's the idea we're going to let
s1 up to s
n be independent
d1 by d2 matrices
so each one of these summands is
independent from the others
each one is a d1 by d2 random matrix
we're going to assume that the
expectation
of sk is equal to zero for each k
if not you should center them
and we're going to assume that each one
of these sks
is uniformly bounded
so this is the spectral norm here it's
the maximum singular value of the matrix
this bound is not random so we are
assuming that the
summands are bounded uniformly
okay now
under these assumptions we'll
consider the random matrix
z that we obtain by summing up
the sk
and we'll define a variance
sigma squared which is the
expectation of the square of z
but z has two squares because it's a
rectangular matrix
and remember this is the maximum so
we're going to compute the variance of z
which is this quantity it's the
expectation of the square
the left square and the right square and
once we have all of this material we can
write down a concentration inequality
for the
spectral norm of z so the probability
that the norm of z
exceeds some level t is less than or
equal to
d1 plus d2 times
the exponential
of minus t squared over two divided by
sigma squared
plus rt divided by three
okay so if you've seen the
matrix-bernstein inequality
then this will look awfully sorry if
you've seen the scalar bernstein
if you've seen the matrix one it will
look extremely familiar if you've seen
the scalar version
it will look somewhat familiar so this
is exactly the formula that you learn
about in
an introductory probability class or in
a
randomized algorithms class or whatever
it tells you that for small t you see
subgaussian behavior
for large t you see better than sub
exponential behavior
the variance locally is controlled by
sigma squared which is this thing i'm
calling the variance
the only difference really is this
dimensional factor d1 plus d2
um one second if um
this these were scalars d1 plus d2 would
be
two which is just what you see in the
scalar case
and if you've actually got a matrix then
this could be pretty big
so you have to eat a dimensional factor
and
the other difference is that the
variance doesn't look quite like it did
in the scalar case
although it reduces to the scalar
variance
if these are one by one random matrices
okay
so this really is an extension of the
bernstein inequality that you know and
um love all right um
yeah so this is always better than all's
veto winter
and the reason is because um roughly
speaking
they have their um um
the their variance parameter is wrong i
mean that's true but it's
um often a factor of the dimension
larger than it ought to be
so it really doesn't get the right
prediction in general
um i can explain more about that in the
next lecture when i talk about how you
prove stuff like this
okay sorry i know you might want to say
that later perhaps but
it's very important that the
expectations are normal absolutely
yes and by the way really the
interesting thing about this result
in my view is not the tail bound it's
the fact that the expectation of the
norm
is controlled by um two sigma squared
log of d1 plus d2
plus r
divided by 3 times the log of d1 plus d2
so this tells you that that
up to this logarithm the variance and
the upper bound
control the spectral norm of this random
matrix
and this result is sharp in the sense
that there are random matrices where you
will see these logarithms
the example that we're going to finish
in just a minute
and this is never any smaller than the
result without the logarithms
okay so this really is the right answer
um no this is the expectation
so the you see the um variance is under
the square root so it um this is
a standard deviation kind of quantity so
this respect
reflects the moderate deviations and
this reflects the large deviations
so this is like a sub-gaussian
term and this is a sub-exponential
consequences of exponential part
yes that third condition that the norm
of sk is bounded
yep uh that doesn't hold for your
example does it
um it will after i impose it
it's two steps ahead um okay
um any questions about the statement
just understand this yes this is exactly
the bond that benefits right
um no it is not exactly the bound ben
has
because he's assuming these guys are
identically distributed basically
okay so not identically distributed
doesn't work the same way it's different
from all invaders because of the very
actually these rank one matrices
um that's not so important what's
important is that um
somehow okay i can write out this
variance more explicitly since this
question has come up twice now
um
they do it's not necessary for the proof
but um you get
the wrong answer for um things that are
not identically distributed
i think maybe it's best just to leave it
at that right now um
like i said i'm mindful the fact that um
i've only been talking for a third as
long as i'm gonna be talking
and that y'all would probably like some
coffee just about now
anything else
yes is the similar statement true if
you're uh going to some kind of boundary
this condition yeah um you can prove a
boundary differences result
that's a bit harder um there's another
method that's a bit better for bounded
differences
but there is a matrix hoofting
inequality matrix of zuma
all of them yeah anything
are there any else on gaussianity but
the appropriate appropriate norm
story in other words really controlling
the
these very volatile variables this is
tail gaussian and what sense oh you mean
like a
central limit theorem type thing
no i don't think anyone's shown anything
like that just yet
um actually no that's not true because
if you look at the bonus
the operator values central limit
theorems in a bonus space i mean it
tells you that these things look like
that long independent sums converge to
um
um like uh
gaussian measures and um extreme
generality and that work goes back to
certainly at least the 80s i mean it's
all in the doing tolerant
so you can certainly leverage or take
advantage of that kind of
deep result for the specific example
okay all right so let's apply this
to this and then we'll
take a break
so what do we need to do to study the
sample covariance matrix
so we need summands
so the sum ands here in our
error estimate are
one over n times x k
x k transpose minus a
so we've just taken the definition of a
hat the sample covariance estimator
plugged it in here
and multiplied and divided a by n
okay so
um a hat minus a is equal to the sum
of these sk and these sk are evidently
independent
they're zero mean
because the expectation of this guy
equals a
all right so we've got the first two
conditions down
what about uniform boundedness well we
don't have that as
has been pointed out so we're going to
assume that into existence
so we're going to assume that x squared
is uniformly bounded by a number b
okay so we're not talking about general
distributions we're talking about
bounded distributions and
with this assumption we can place a
uniform bound on
the summands
so we have space for this no we need
another board
okay so under this assumption we can
bound
s k
as
one over n times x k x k transpose plus
a
and i'm going to rewrite a as the
expectation of x x transpose
okay now we apply the triangle
inequality for the norm and jensen's
inequality for the expectation
oh you're absolutely right um
so now we apply the uniform bound
for this norm and this one and we obtain
an estimate of 2b over n
for each one of the summands so each of
the summands is uniformly bounded which
is not a surprise because they're
identically distributed and we're
assuming this distribution
is bounded okay now the last piece we
need to compute the variance
so this is uh particularly easy in this
case because
this is a symmetric matrix and so
sk sk transpose equals sk
transpose sk is equal to sk squared
so this thing here is only going to have
one term in it instead of two
and so the expectation
of sk squared
is 1 over n squared times the
expectation
of
x k squared times x k x k
transpose minus
x k x k transpose times a
minus x k trans uh whoops minus a
times x k x k transpose
plus a squared
so all we've done here is
expanded the square
now this is bounded by b
and this is non-negative so we can make
this larger in the semi-definite order
by replacing this with b
and once we do that we can just compute
the expectation
so this is dominated by 1 over n
squared times the expectation of
b times the covariance a
minus a times a minus a
times a so a
squared minus a squared plus
a squared and
these three combine to produce a
matrix that's non-positive and so in
summary
the expectation of one of these summands
is one over n
squared times b
times a in the semi-definite order
all right now we're prepared to compute
this variance
and as soon as we compute the variance
we can apply the theorem
so
expectation of z squared
is equal to the expectation of the
sum of s k
times s j
where j and k range over all of the
possible values of the indices but
these guys are independent when the
indices are different
and they are mean zero
so this collapses to the diagonal terms
and so we can just substitute in our
bound here
where we've used the fact that the sum
has n terms
and now we just simplify this to b
over n times the norm of a
okay so you need to be a little bit
careful introducing things
um inequalities into spectral norms but
this calculation is pretty reasonable
and it gives you an estimate for the
variance parameter
of the um sorry the random matrix should
have been um
a hat minus a all right now
we have everything we need to apply this
theorem and so
we discovered that the expectation of
a hat minus a
is less than or equal to the square root
of 2
times b over n
times norm a this is sigma squared
times the logarithm of the dimension
of the matrix d1 and d2 so what are the
dimensions of z
well this is a covariance matrix for p
variables so it's just p
by p so both of the dimensions equal p
so the first term here is
log 2p and then we have this uniform
bound here that we need to include so
the uniform bound is 2b
over n
and again we have the logarithm of 2p
okay so we've computed the
expected error or a bound on the
expected error and the sample covariance
matrix
as an estimator of the sample as an
estimator of the covariance
and the is in the spectral norm so it's
very strong it controls every marginal
of the distribution all right now what
does this mean
so if we would like this to be smaller
than epsilon
what we need is that the number of
samples n
is going to be bigger than
a constant times b
log of 2p divided by
epsilon squared times the spectral norm
of the matrix a
the covariance
so if we want a small error this is the
number of samples we need
so most of the time in applications of
interest
b is going to be about equal to p the
number of variables
and the conclusion that you reach them
is that you need
n to be something like p log p over
epsilon squared is the number of samples
to perform accurate covariance
estimation
okay this is sharp for worst case
distributions
and this calculation which took a little
longer than i
might have liked but nevertheless can be
completed on two
chalkboards establishes a result from
rudelson
paper in 1999 on
the distributions of isotropic random
vectors this is considered a major
result
before this time you really needed to
have
really like the intellect and talent of
jean borgen to
produce um results of this form
now it amounts to
a piece of arithmetic that you can do on
a chalkboard at the end of a
one-hour lecture so
that's the value of these results you
can get
results that are often accurate or close
to accurate
with a minimum of effort even if they
aren't
quite as informative as the very best
results for um the standard
ensembles um it should be said that for
um distributions on x that are not worst
case
you don't need that logarithm and this
result won't tell you that
so that's the trade-off
calculation that fits on these boards
but it can't tell you whether or not the
logarithm belongs
so for many purposes that's adequate
okay let's take a break and we'll start
again in
15 minutes thank you
is